hasta el pasado 24 de febrero cuando el
presidente ruso vladimir putin ordenó la
invasión a ucrania las elecciones
parlamentarias en hungría que están
programadas para este domingo estaban
dominadas por temas que van como la
corrupción la economía o el papel de
hungría en la unión europea para
entonces y por primera vez en una década
el partido de gobierno al fidesz que
lidera el primer ministro viktor orbán
estaba teniendo su hegemonía amenazada
está por una coalición de partidos
políticos conocida como todos por
hungría que incluye tanto a partidos de
izquierda como de derecha y que están
dominados por el líder político peter y
markas y todavía están siendo amenazados
por ello solamente tienen unos cuatro
puntos de diferencia entre unos y otros
pero el escenario de estas elecciones ha
cambiado radicalmente desde la llegada
de esta guerra el primer ministro viktor
orbán cambió su discurso y dice que él
es el único que puede dar la paz y la
seguridad de este país se acusa a los
opositores de querer involucrar hungría
en la guerra con ucrania viktor orbán
también ha cambiado su posición frente a
los refugiados ha permitido la entrada
de más de 350.000 ucranianos algo
totalmente diferente a lo que sucedió
con siria y con afganos en su momento
también ha permitido el fortalecimiento
de las tropas de la otan a al oeste del
río danubio pero se ha negado a que
desde aquí pasen armas a ucrania esto
también es bastante significativo porque
la mayoría de los electores de viktor
orbán al menos el 50 por ciento de ellos
rechazan la guerra en ucrania aún así
siguen apoyando a su líder político que
en el pasado siempre fue vinculado con
rusia pero especialmente con el
presidente vladimir putin